P.R. CONVERSATION ABOUT HOW
THE TRUMP TEAM WOULD
POSITION THIS AND WHAT THEY
COULD SAY ABOUT THIS.
>> IT'S THE FBI'S DIRECTOR
JOB TO COME IN AND TELL THE
PRESIDENT-ELECT EVERYTHING
THAT THEY KNEW ABOUT ALLEGED
RUSSIAN INTERFERENCE.
HE DIDN'T DO THAT.
WHY IS IT UP TO THE
PRESIDENT-ELECT AND THE
MEMBERS OF THE TEAM WHO WERE
IN THERE.
>> Bret: WELL, IT'S JUST
BEGINNING ON THIS FRONT.
JAMES COMEY THE FORMER FBI
DIRECTOR AND THE PRESIDENT
BACK AND FOR THE.
COMEY'S BOOK COMING OUT.
AN INTERVIEW THIS WEEKEND.
AND WE'RE GETTING JUST SOME
PIECES OF THAT IN THAT HE
WRITES THE PRESIDENT IS
UNETHICAL AND UNTETHERED TO
TRUTH AND THE INSTITUTIONAL
VALUES.
HIS LEADERSHIP IS
TRANSACTIONAL, EGO-DRIVEN
AND ABOUT PERSONAL LOYALTY.
THE PRESIDENT TWEETING TODAY
JAMES COMEY IS A PROVEN
LEAKER AND LIAR.
VIRTUALLY EVERYONE IN
WASHINGTON THOUGHT HE SHOULD
BE FIRED FOR THE TERRIBLE
JOB HE DID UNTIL HE WAS, IN
FACT FIRED.
HE LEAKED CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION FOR WHICH HE
SHOULD BE PROSECUTED.
HE LIED TO CONGRESS UNDER
OATH.
HE IS A WEAK AND UNTRUTHFUL
SLIME BALL WHO WAS AS TIME
HAS PROVEN A TERRIBLE
DIRECTOR OF THE FBI.
HIS HANDLING OF THE CROOKED
HILLARY CLINTON CASE AND THE
EVENTS SURROUNDING IT WILL
GO DOWN AS ONE OF THE MOST
BOTCHED JOBS OF HISTORY.
IT WAS MY GREAT HONOR TO
FIRE JAMES COMEY.
A LOT OF NEWS ON THAT FRONT
AND A LOT OF FRONTS FRANKLY
THIS WEEK.
LET'S BRING IN OUR PANEL
MATT SCHLAPP TRIBUTER
CONTRIBUTOR WITH THE HILL.
TOM CATANESE AND
TOM CATANESE WND
TOM CATANESE WRITER WITH THE
WASHINGTON EXAMINER.
PUT THIS IN CATEGORIES
BEFORE WE TALK ABOUT COHEN
AND ALL THAT.
THIS BACK AND FORTH WITH
COMEY AND WHAT'S COMING OUT.
MATT?
>> YEAH, I MEAN, AMAZING
TWEET FROM THE PRESIDENT.
I HAVE TO SAY IT CAPTURE
WHAT IS A LOT OF PEOPLE
THINK ABOUT THE GUY.
DEMOCRATS AND REPUBLICANS.
I WENT THROUGH ALL THE
TWEETS FROM HARRY REID TO
CHUCK SCHUMER TO NANCY
PELOSI.
YOU HAVE ALL OF THOSE ON THE
RIGHT WHO THINK HE IS
ALSO -- FOR ME IT'S VERY
PERSONAL BECAUSE I DEALT
WITH JAMES COMEY WHEN HE
FIRST CAME INTO THE BUSH
ADMINISTRATION.
AND HE PURPORTED TO ME THAT
HE WAS THIS REALLY STRONG
CONSERVATIVE REPUBLICAN.
BUT WHEN WE DID A POLITICAL
CHECK, WE FOUND PEOPLE
SAYING THAT HE TOLD THE
DEMOCRATS HE WAS A DEMOCRAT.
HE TOLD REPUBLICANS HE WAS A
REPUBLICAN.
WHAT YOU REALIZE WITH JIM
COMEY IT IS ALL ABOUT HIM.
IS HE AT THE END OF HIS
ROPE.
I DON'T KNOW WHERE HIS
POLITICAL FRIENDS ARE
ANYMORE.
>> Bret: I HAVE NOT READ THE
BOOK.
I WILL PRIOR TO THIS
INTERVIEW COMING UP
APRIL 26TH.
HERE IS THE WHITE HOUSE
PRESS SECRETARY TODAY ON
THESE COMEY CHARGES.
>> THE AMERICAN PEOPLE SEE
RIGHT THROUGH THE BLATANT
LIES OF A SELF-ADMITTED
LEAKER.
THIS IS NOTHING MORE THAN A
POORLY EXECUTED P.R. STUNT
BY COMEY TO DESPERATELY
REHABILITATE HIS TATTERED
REPUTATION AND ENRICH HIS
OWN BANK ACCOUNT BY PEDDLING
A BOOK THAT BELONGINGS IN
THE BARGAIN BIN OF THE
FICTION SECTION.
>> I WAS SURPRISED.
I DON'T THINK THERE WITH A
BOMBSHELL IN THIS COMEY BOOK
AT ALL.
THE PRESIDENT WAS UPSET
ABOUT THE DOSSIER AND GOING
TO THE FBI DIRECTOR AND
ASKING HIM ABOUT IT TO ME,
THAT'S A NATURAL HUMAN
REACTION IF YOU ARE ACCUSED
OF SOME OF THOSE THINGS.
I DO THINK THE MOST
INTERESTING THING OUT OF
THIS WAS COMEY ADMITTING
THAT HE MADE A POLITICAL
DECISION WHEN IT CAME TO
RELEASING THAT HILLARY
CLINTON LETTER JUST DAYS
BEFORE THE ELECTION ABOUT
HER EMAILS.
WE ALWAYS WERE TOLD, RIGHT,
THE FBI IS ABOVE POLITICS.
HE IS BASICALLY ADMITTING
THAT, NO, THE FBI DOES TAKE
POLITICS INTO CONSIDERATION
BECAUSE WE THOUGHT HILLARY
WAS GOING TO WIN SO HE
DIDN'T THINK THIS LETTER WAS
GOING TO BE THAT DAMAGING.
THAT TO ME IS THE MOST
INTERESTING THING IN THE
MATTER.
>> Bret: ENTIRELY POSSIBLE
BECAUSE I WAS MAKING
DECISIONS IN AN ENVIRONMENT
WHERE HILLARY CLINTON WAS
SURE TO BE THE NEXT
PRESIDENT, MY CONCERN ABOUT
MAKING HER AN ILLEGITIMATE
PRESIDENT BY CONCEALING THE
RESTART OF THE INVESTIGATION
BORE GREATER WEIGHT THAN IT
WOULD HAVE IF THE ELECTION
APPEARED CLOSER OR IF DONALD
TRUMP WERE AHEAD IN ALL
POLLS.
BUT I DON'T KNOW.
TOM, THE OTHER NEWS TODAY
THAT'S GETTING EVERYBODY'S
ATTENTION IS THIS I.G.
REPORT ON MCCABE AND WHY HE
WAS FIRED.
PRETTY SIGNIFICANT.
>> IT IS SIGNIFICANT.
THE DEPTH OF DETAIL.
I WAS SPEAKING TO A FRIEND
WHO WORKS IN THE GOVERNMENT.
HE WAS VERY SKEPTICAL AT
THIS REPORT BEFORE IT CAME
OUT.
TODAY YOU LOOK AT THE
MEASURE OF DETAIL REPEATED
ACCUSATIONS.
IT BECOMES VERY HARD, I
THINK, TO SEE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR MCCABE IN THE KIND
OF POSITIVE LIGHT THAT
PERHAPS HE HAS TRIED TO
PRESENT HIMSELF SINCE THE
FIRING.
AND AGAIN IN THE CONTEXT OF
THE COMEY BOOK WHICH I AGREE
WITH DAVID DOESN'T ACTUALLY
HAVE THE TANGIBLE BOMBSHELL
THAT WE WERE LED TO BELIEVE,
FRANKLY YOU HAVE TO THINK
FROM THE PRESIDENT'S POINT
OF VIEW THIS WILL LOOK
PRETTY GOOD FOR HIM.
THEN YOU WONDER WELL, WHY
DOES HE TWEET ABOUT IT?
PERHAPS THAT'S THE EMOTIONAL
THING.
>> Bret: CHAIRMAN GOODLATTE
WEIGHED IN ON THIS IG REPORT
SAYING MR. MCCABE REPEATEDLY
LIED UNDER OATH ABOUT THE
DISCLOSURE OF INFORMATION TO
A REPORTER.
IN DOING SO, HE NOT ONLY
VIOLATED FBI POLICY, BUT HE
MAY HAVE COMMITTED A FEDERAL
CRIME.
IT IS UNFORTUNATE THAT
MR. MCCABE'S DISTINGUISHED
CAREER AT THE FBI HAS ENDED
THIS WAY, BUT IT IS APPARENT
THAT ATTORNEY GENERAL
SESSIONS MADE THE RIGHT
DECISION.
HIS ATTORNEY HAS RELEASED A
STATEMENT SAYING HE DIDN'T
BELIEVE THAT THE IG'S REPORT
WAS ACCURATE OR COMPLETE.
MATT, YOU SAW THE FBI
DIRECTOR CHRIS WRAY SAYING
THAT THIS WENT BY THE BOOK,
AS YOU READ THE DETAILS OF
THIS IG REPORT, IT SEEMS
LIKE THEY HAD ENOUGH THERE
THERE.
>> 30 PAGES THAT GOES INTO
DETAIL ABOUT WHY MCCABE
BROKE.
LET'S JUST SAY IT THIS WAY.
EVERY POLICY ABOUT THIS,
THAT THE FBI HAS, EVEN BROKE
COMEY'S OWN POLICIES ABOUT
HOW YOU DEAL WITH THE PRESS.
AND LET'S REMEMBER, THIS IS
AN OBAMA APPOINTED IG
CONFIRMED BY THE SENATE.
THIS IS NOT A DONALD TRUMP
APPOINTEE WHO IS TRYING TO
SETTLE SCORES.
THIS IS A FARE-MINDED I.G.
LOOKING AT THE RECORD AND
THE RECORD IS TERRIBLE.
AND AS AN AMERICAN, I HATE
TO THINK THAT THIS ACTUALLY
HAPPENED AT THE FBI.
I WANT TO THINK THAT THIS
DOESN'T HAPPEN.
>> Bret: OKAY.
SCOOTER LIBBY PARDONED
TODAY.
THE PRESIDENT IN A STATEMENT
SAYING:  I DON'T KNOW
MR. LIBBY BUT FOR YEARS I
HAVE HEARD THAT HE HAS BEEN
TREATED UNFAIRLY.
HOPEFULLY THIS FULL PARDON
WILL HELP RECTIFY A VERY SAD
PORTION OF HIS LIFE.
THIS IS A VERY BIG VICTORY
FOR DICK CHENEY WHO WANTED
GEORGE W. BUSH TO DO THIS
VERY THING.
HE DID NOT.
BUT, IS IT DEEPER THAN THAT?
A SIGNAL WHEN A SPECIAL
COUNSEL, A SPECIAL
INVESTIGATOR IS CHARGING
PEOPLE AND IS IT A MESSAGE
TO OTHER PEOPLE SAYING I
HAVE YOUR BACK LATER ON?
>> YEAH.
I TRIED TO REACH OUT AND
TALK TO SOME WHITE HOUSE
OFFICIALS ABOUT THIS.
WHY TODAY?
WHAT WAS THE SIGNIFICANCE OF
TODAY?
AND, LOOK, REMEMBER, GEORGE
W. BUSH PASSED ON A PARDON
FOR SCOOTER LIBBY, WHY IS
DONALD TRUMP IN HIS OWN
STATEMENT HE IS SAYING I
DON'T REALLY KNOW THE CASE.
I DON'T KNOW THE GUY.
BUT IT SEEMS LIKE HE WAS
TREATED UNFAIRLY.
TO ME THIS WAS A SIGNAL TO
HIS OTHER AIDES THAT HE HAS
THE POWER TO INOCULATE THEM
IF THEY COME UNDER FIRE.
TO ME, YOU CAN'T READ IT ANY
OTHER WAY, ESPECIALLY WITH
ALL THIS OTHER NEWS WITH
COMEY AND MCCABE.
>> Bret: HERE SARAH SANDERS
SPECIFICALLY ASKED ABOUT
THAT ASPECTS OF POTENTIAL
LINKAGE THERE.